If you look closely, these glasses are monogrammed with the letter 'T' because I bought them for my brother Tim like two or three years ago
Christmas and they didn't get delivered in time
And so I just kept them. Tim, here's what it could have been!
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig
if you did not know, now you know, your life is different now! Welcome to another video in which I comment on your comments
Let's jump right into it. Let's start over on
instagram
I feel pressured to post there on a
Daily Basis. Doctor person. New Person! New Person! New Person! For all of you who don't know when a new person comments on one of my social media platforms I grace the crap out
of them, it's great family basically
I just sort of say a bunch of random things about a person's username
And we all get there eventually doctor person more like lawyer robot. You've been Graced!
rPTr season 10 looks
interesting
Yes, everyone is live looking for their lives and lips became further muscle
Live we still don't know if Hanna memmer married days at least by my eyes. I leave more like days and
Released it's how I feel like every time I go out of house through a grace
I was on the phone with my friend today, and she was talking and I was giving her monotone answers
And she said you know who you sound like right now
at Grace Helbig and
naturally I got both excited and confused so I was like why is that and she said because you are so mama toned and
uninterested and I said oh not true and
Idk why I felt the need to share that with you, but I did so you are welcome
wet face emoJi
Wow, thank you for this anecdote. It's always nice to know that people think my brand is
genuinely Monotone and uninterested
I did take a theater class in college once and I think my acting instructor would be so upset
But that's the brand I've cultivated. Hey subscribe be on a car. Pee a cube, and I got a car pee at my briana's car
To you on that pee on your car clean your territory you got that kia soul for a reason super great
Where are your ugh? Oh? Yeah?
This is left on a photo of me chugging gatorade in the wilderness and the thing that is not pictured in this photo are
An actual pair of Forest green eggs, I will
In the wild you can take the girls jersey, but the jersey girl is going to take the eggs with her everywhere
She goes yeah, let's go really
great the main
difference if I
May with more like racing names are going to montreal just for laughs you are in Montreal and want to come to us, too
Sentiments of haha from Sunday night look at our social media profiles there will be information about tickets
There you have a great quality hangover outfit. Thank you very feel big ah
Onan way too hot on my excitement Rosella wearing
And I don't know sweatshirt undone forget that I made this picture for you guys
And I love it so much that I was recently thinking about possibly doing some other merge. Which I don't know on it
let me know you think I don't know merge is something you would be interested in you can use the
Commenting section down below to do so with that spoken word
I didn't spoken word poetry look out Hamilton
Wx destroy our new version of us destroyer more like just destroyer you seem awful good grades absolutely no one cared
Wow, but there's some fiber in your being I cared enough to tweet this out with perfect grammar and punctuation
so x destroyer
Yes, I'll go to prom with You Loie Anger boomerang more like Low Angles high
Dismissals of like on photo human boot if my Tampon just fell out wow this is
something I relate to and also that woman has an amazing but
Bethenny we know Florida remembers me when bethenny we know for what I said to you is
Girl for this is the magazine. I guess because I'm not forgetting anymore
Do great love this film dirty Thirty movie hard ptomaine time great ally when someone tells you that they haven't watched it
Yeah at Jawline Gotta cut a bitch that hasn't watched dirty dirty movie Gonna do a movie calm or watch it
Where it's available great a bug now let's go to Mary Lou
When you're here, you're family
Beater rust removers to where indeed are us more like oh, man that girl
was so dry would you had to have sex a fairy you were probably like oh, what's what's going on, so Regina d vera
What no you look great as a guy? I'm glad my tampons don't fall out
Yeah
Isn't that amazing that you have to deal with that every thirty days wow light of that perhaps you should take an effort to support
Women's health wow leading heartening for today leading are more like leaving Sharks humid word. You are a funny girl
Keep up the good work grace, okay?
So it seems that my mother has created another youtube account because I have not returned her phone calls. Hi, Mom. I'm well!
Thank you for your positive support. I love you. Let's work on a new icon for your YouTube channel okay, BB
Hey, BB more like are you okay? BB? You're not. Alright, well, you tried.
Eat my whole.
I think I'm gonna go vegan. Well there you go. That's it for commenting on your comments this week
Thank you guys so much for leaving so many colorful comments on all of my social media platforms. If you want to follow me
anywhere, all the links are in description box below
Give this video a thumbs up if you like commenting on comments videos!
And subscribe to this YouTube channel. Click that subscribe button and there's like a little bell thing that you can click and it gives you
notifications when I upload a video. Because I like to say that I upload Monday Wednesday and Friday
But we all know that that's not true. That little bell thing will help you know when I actually do it. I don't know.
Piptation, more like pap smear. I should get one. Personal note. YOU'VE BEEN GRACED. "Omg grace you're outdoors so much lately..."
"...I'm a bit concerned."
Heart face emoji. I am too.
I think I want to do what you do when you get a pet and you put a microchip in them
So if they get lost you can figure out where they are so I think I'm going to do that for myself
so if I go too far into nature
you guys will be able to reel me back in. Please dear god. I'm getting too much vitamin d, I think. I'm like happy
That doesn't make for good YouTube videos...